who would have thought that the
cheerfully vulgar stunt show jackass
would prove to be one of the most
enduring media properties
of the 21st century whether or not you
place money on its success the fourth
feature-length film of the franchise
is set to debut on october 22nd 2021
in fact a brand new trailer for jackass
forever just dropped and if you're a
long time fan
you might have noticed a disappointing
absence the trailer for jackass forever
begins with a peppy song and title cards
asking the question
when was the last time you got together
with old friends to laugh your asses off
what follows is two minutes of pure
tomfoolery as johnny knoxville stevo and
jackass team members old and new
participate in a series of death-defying
stunts that will have you wincing in
discomfort
and howling with laughter in equal
measure it's clear though that one old
friend is missing from the chaos
bam majera not only is majera absent
from the teasers for jackass forever
itself
but he's also not prominently featured
in any of the archival footage
that appears in the trailer if you grew
up watching him on jackass or a spin-off
series viva la bam
you're likely curious about his absence
back in february 2021 majira posted a
series of videos to his personal
instagram page claiming
among other things that he had been
booted from the production of jackass
forever
majira said in the video jackass does
not care about me
understand that ladies and gentlemen it
was like my family it won't let me in
because they say i'm out there being a
jackass on tmz
so i can't be in jackass because i'm out
there being a jackass
in april tmz followed up with majira
about this relationship with the film
during a taped interview he claimed that
he was pressured by somebody in
production to do a 90-day stint in rehab
which resulted in him being placed on a
number of different medications majira
says this led to him experiencing
suicidal tendencies
telling tmz what's the point of a five
million dollar contract that they have
to walk on eggshells and jump through
your hoops
which is already impossible to obey if
i'm dead he called the experience
torture and implied that he planned on
taking legal action
against production it's supposed to be a
[__] reunion to pay our respects to
ryan dunn
dunn one of the original stars of the
franchise died in 2011.
during his criticism of the film's
production magera called out several
members of the crew specifically
including johnny knoxville director jeff
the main ended up fighting a restraining
order against majera
during a may 2021 profile in gq johnny
knoxville took the time to touch on
majera's accusations
and ultimate absence from jackass
forever although he didn't delve deep
into the details of the situation
it's clear that the episode was painful
for knoxville we want bam to be happy
and healthy and get the help he needs
we tried to push that along i think
that's all i really want to say about it
i don't want to get into public back and
forth with bam i just want him to get
better
speaking generally about mental health
and substance abuse issues at various
cast members have faced over the years
knoxville said i think each of us was
responsible for his own actions and when
someone's struggling everyone tries to
help that person
and at the end of the day that person
has to want help sometimes they don't
yet jack has forever are slated to hit
theaters on october 22nd
2021 if you or anyone you know is
struggling with addiction issues
help is available please call the
substance abuse and mental health
administration's 24 7 national helpline
at 1-800-662-help that's 1-800-662-4357